au début son surnom ce n'était pas belle
mais c'était pepel pour la raison
suivante sa bande de copains au
conservatoire où il y avait pas avec
quelques bons acteurs aussi un jean
pierre marielle jean rochefort bruno
crémer de trémeur le surnomme people en
référence à ppl vasca le voleur
interprété par jean gabin dans les bas
fonds car plus jeunes belmondo portait
toujours le même pull fatigués à cause
d'une faute de frappe c'est devenu bébel
jeu et 20 est ce que vous confirmez ou
est ce que c'est une légende urbaine je
pense que c'était une légende mais bon
malheureusement il n'y a plus beaucoup
de monde pour la mais cela dit en fait
il est vraiment devenu bébel avec
d'abord cartouches mais surtout avec
l'homme de rio c'est là où on fait un
mot c'est mon film culte en a parlé avec
gérard et c'est en fait une sorte de
tintin bondissant et c'est là où
belmondo devient bébel et après pendant
des années il va alterner des films
belmondo des finb est belle et c'est ça
en fait le la puissance de cet acteur
c'est d'avoir joué sur ce double
registre mais les collègues de du
conservatoire ne sont ne sont plus là
évidemment pour la plupart mais ils ont
quand même beaucoup parlé et quand même
un aspect qui ressort de belmondo à
l'époque c'était un déconneur c'est un
cherbourg mort d'un des leurs un
blagueur ils ont écumé la rue
saint-benoît ils ont fait les pitres il
faisait semblant de se bagarrer dans la
rue pour choquer les passants le
meilleur belmondo n'a pas été filmé en
fait peut-être ils ne paient pas les
consos fin c'était la petite bande il
faisait les 400 coups napper c'était
formidable parce que dans les hôtels ou
leaf on est un souk pas possible il
raconte à chaque fois qu évidemment le
lendemain ils allaient payer qu'on lui
dit et ont usé mais vous avez passé une
bonne soirée bon ben c'est pour nous
alors mottaki mot ce qu'il avait gardé
ce côté déconneur dollar juste pour
revenir à l'anecdote de paypal justement
gg la réponse d'années à l'époque à
perdre et c'est bien parce que j'ai
passé mon confinement et jean paul et
donc on ne pouvait rien faire donc je
suis allé dans son garage j'ai ramené
des livres et avait les mémoires d'un
acteur qui s'appelle hubert deschamps
alors que la jeune génération ne connaît
pas c'était le médecin dans les sous
doués en vacances et c'est hubert
deschamps qui est au théâtre avec jean
paul et jean paul venait toujours avec
soi même pub c'est hubert deschamps qui
a trouvé surnom de paypal et qui a
pressé transformant bébel nous allons
l'arrêté concernant l'histoire des
armoires à glace c'est vrai que jean
paul avait l'habitude de déplacer tous
les meubles et sur staline qui l'art est
né il y avait un grand comédien qui
s'appelait françois perrier est rentré
tard le soir il s'était bien ben yamin
avec ses potes il y avait la suite de
françois périer ils prennent une armoire
normande en règle à cela pose devant la
chambre ça ne pouvait pas sortir
et il fera mais s'il de 3 heures du
matin et il frappe à la porte il
françois périer évidemment avec sa fin
la chance d'ouvrir
dans les trois mois si réveillés et nous
la vitre jamais sa femme fils c'est qui
fait débat c'est moi
ribéry jong un avec l'âge il avait gardé
ce côté là bas mais je peux dire lors
aller chercher sa nature profonde à
beichuan lire alors je sais que mon
malin va être pardonné et puis bon
guillaume et aux modes dont je peux lire
marion cotillard était en tournage à
cannes et à la v7 nous on avait nos deux
chambres et puis il avait sa suite au
milieu des autres et on rentre en soir
assez tard et je crois qu'ils rentrent
il dit il montre son ticket du petit
déjeuner il dit change avec la chambre
d'en face sur hubert deschamps il fait
trop peur des chansons il est sympa il a
joué aussi dans un puits à la wii est
pas fait que les sous doués mais non
c'est un grand public en fait il a
inversé le le petit déj de marion
cotillard avec la chambre d'en face
voilà c'était c'était il ya cinq six ans
resté jusqu'au bout
c'est le spécialiste vous que de vous
mettre du sel lanka fait dès que vous
avez le dos tourné